l'année dernière j'ai lancé mon nouveau
spectacle singularité à l'olympia et on
est parti en tournée dans plus de 50
villes avec plus de 30000 spectateurs
qui sont venus le voir je repars en
tournée avec la version 2 parce que
maintenant il ya des écrans géants des
nouveautés des petites choses qui ont
changé
je serai bientôt dans le 77 à ces rites
dans le xii dans le 25 dans le 38 dans
le procès en suisse en belgique dans
plusieurs villes aux antilles en
polynésie en nouvelle calédonie non ce
n'est pas une blague dans 40 villes en
france et à paris le 31 décembre on fera
le réveillon ensemble
vous avez toutes les dates toutes les
infos toutes les villes sur le site
internet les une carte interactive où tu
peux voir si hattab il ya aussi un
moteur de recherche ou tu peux taper ça
directement vous allez le lien dans la
barre d'infos venez c'est une expérience
de dingue pour vous comme pour moi donc
à bientôt sur la nouvelle tournée du
spectacle
oui j'ai hâte que se passe-t-il sur
cette chaîne bonjour à tous vous avez vu
le titre en a parlé d'astrologie c'est
un petit peu bizarre
alors oui on va aujourd'hui rencontrer
un astrologue pourquoi je vous raconte
la démarche
j'ai rencontré jean il ya quelques temps
par l'intermédiaire d'amis dans un bar
et donc ils scandale toujours avec les
éphémérides c'est un bouquin qui donne
la position des planètes sur notre jour
de naissance et lui il a une
méthodologie pour lire sa factuellement
il dit ça veut dire évidemment j'ai un
rapport scientifique autre chose je n'ai
pas la croyance dans les pièces dans
l'astrologie est tout néanmoins c'est un
gars hyper passionné passionnant je dis
est ce que tu veux venir sur la chaîne
on en parle tu nous explique ce que
c'est et on se fait une démonstration
mais les personnes dont je vais te
demander de lire le thème astrologique
je ne vais pas te dire qu'ici je te
donne ajusta date de naissance et leur
de naissance et on verra un petit peu si
ça colle ou pas voici la démarche
aujourd'hui
prenez le avec un certain lâcher prise
on n'est pas là pour y croire on est là
pour voir ce que fait jean yves lui avec
son truc et comment il fait ses analyses
s'intéressant c'est curieux c'est juste
comme ça c'est du mental fun loïc
général
[Musique]
donc j'ai ici les différentes enveloppes
que fanni a préparé avec les dates de
naissance le genre de la personne et
marqué dessus mais avant qu'on s'attelle
à ça explique nous comment tu vas faire
parce que ça moi je connais un outil qui
ressemble à ça mais c'est pour aller
voir si je vais ramasser des crabes des
vidéos en flash le principe est tout
simple
le principe c'est que je travaille à
partir d'un bouquin qui s'appelle des
éphémérides ça sert à deux corps de
métier les marins et les astrologues
lehmann puis j'ai donc gps plus aucun
intérêt en revanche non sans faire
toujours j'ai toutes les latitudes
toutes les latitudes des planètes de
notre système solaire
et puis là dessus je me repose sur cinq
éléments majeurs qui vont être le soleil
la lune donc conscient et inconscient
je m'appuyais sur mercure la façon dont
est un communiqué sur vénus la manière
dont quelque 4 m
vachon important de savoir une lettre à
m et puis mars
si on a affaire à quelqu'un qui se prend
par la main dans la vie si c'est des
courageux bosseur ou si il se laisse
vivre en gros comment il fait face aux
cff de l'existence donc j'ai une green
spontanément de cinq paramètres sur
lesquels je fonce pour calibrer
d'instinct ce que j'en ai fait valide
avant dé le delta entre les besoins de
quelqu'un ait les moyens de quelques
hoquets genre et d'épaves voyant mon but
c'est pas que tu devines qui a dans les
enveloppes
ok on va prendre aussi nous un paramètre
en compte qui est que la personne
publique n'est pas forcément comme ça
dans la vraie vie c'est à dire que vous
vous connaissez une facette de moi mais
vous ne me connaissez pas réellement
dans tous les détails et dans toute la
complexité de qui je suis donc là c'est
un petit peu pareil peut-être on va être
surpris de certaines choses et on va
voir ça parce que toi tu vas faire une
lecture à l'aveuglé avec des outils là
et on s'appuie en fait sur une
méthodologie et c'est ça que je trouve
assez passionnant de s'appuyer sur des
données une méthodologie et d'en
extraire quelque chose avec aussi 30 ans
d'expérience oeuvre on commence bien
est ce que tu vas en choisir une au
hasard où je la choisis soit ce qu'il
choisit
donc nous sommes le 14 juin 1946 ok il
est 10h 54 un homme né il est né du
rugby ça commence bien
qu'est ce que veut le soleil soleil
principe des god anting des gémeaux il
faut communiquer il veut bouger votre
mobile il veut être libye veut découvrir
des trucs toute la journée c'est un
éternel ado qui en mouvement permanent
en ce qui concerne la lune ce qu'il ya
au fond des tripes la lune en sagittaire
c'est un type qui peut avoir des
réflexes assez franc assez rentre-dedans
assez intuitif ac c'est boum boum c'est
comme ça donc il peut avoir au fond une
tendance à être un peu dominant et un
peu push le soleil et très gémeaux donc
très calmes et des entrées gamin très
ado est au fond j'ai une lune instinct
superpuissance agitèrent qui fait qu'ils
te vole dans les plumes i30 dedans ils
se coupent issa mais qui tient pas en
place l'une sagittaire ça donne des gens
qui voyagent qu'ils bougent pour besoins
de mobilité permanente
après il a mercure cancer faut se méfier
ce qu'on lui raconte pas ce qu'il doit à
une mémoire d'éléphant mercure qui est
le mental d'intelligence dire que vous
lui dit un truc dix ans après ils s'en
souviendront faire gaffe à ce qu'on vit
raconte pourquoi lui faire des promesses
qu'on n'est pas sûr parce qu'il va pour
tomber sur le coin du pif et puis va
vous ball et qui savent pas de mal se
passer
il n'y a pas plus que sar que le marsan
lyon je vous explique pourquoi
parce que le lion c'est comme l'animal
dans la savane dire qu'il est capable de
roupiller toute la journée au soleil mm
pour être près du point d'eau d'une demi
heure plus tard il ya une gazelle car il
est notre marsan lyon islah m et sur 100
m il court plus vite que tout ce qui
existe
ils bouffent la gazelle il se rendort
pendant trois semaines c'est des rois
des bâches page marsan lyon ça peut
donner un type qui va avoir un côté
dominant parce qu'on sait depuis 4000
ans qu'un corse qu'un gamin des avec
mars l'action l'agressivité sur
l'horizon ce qu'on appelle l'ascendant
ça donne des tempéraments un peu un peu
dominante
voilà c'était hyper intéressant parce
que cette personne là est vraiment très
proche du point d'eau est en ce moment
puisque c'est donald trump
je trouve ça hyper intéressant que tu
parles de son intelligence parce que il
passe pour un gros bonnet n'empêche que
si ça a été l'homme d'affaires qui l'a
été c'est que par contre oui il doit
avoir une certaine mémoire oui il doit
avoir une certaine intelligence parce
que tu gères pas des affaires comme ça
ça veut pas dire que c'est un malin
social c'est clair mais
par contre ça montre qu'il a su gérer
son business après tout ce qui était
dominant c'est etc
on était en plein dedans pendant donc
d'un jeune homme qui est né le 27
janvier 1996
un homme dont on n'a pas son heure
d'accord j'aurais peut-être une variable
sur les eaux parce que la lune a fait 17
degrés par jour et 17 degrés par jour en
bois de change tous les jours et fait
son tour en 28 jours dans tous les cas
des rues 30 euros donc un seul morceau
original créatif pas faire comme tout le
monde fasse fil à la patte indépendant
voilà ces vecteurs
c'est un signe vers donc il est dans la
com il est dans les changes dessine dès
ce qui est sympa c'est qu'ils ont lâché
prise sur la matière du sur l'ego du feu
- mois des emmerdes bd on se gère pas la
recrue le son deuxième pilier qui est sa
lune
elle est en taureau donc le ton gars
sont là il a quand même un côté
jouisseur qui aime bien son confort qui
aime bien la paix au quotidien alors lui
il n'aime pas qu'on leur gueule grave
autant un signe de feu tu peux voler
dedans parce qu'ils adorent ça il sait
ici que si tu là dessus autant lui a
qu'un soleil verso j'ai dit
l'affrontement ou j'évite parce que ça
les énergies ça ne pollue et la lune
taureau il est bien tranquille aime bien
qu'on l'ait vachement des tributaires
qu'on aime d'ailleurs qui les ont
partagés entre le peinard dans son
canapé en cuir avec ses bonnes choses
avoue le thé est en même temps le sac à
dos qui est prêt dans l'entrée où il a
qu'une envie c'est ce bar et et le le
dilemme mido est permanent il a mercure
capricorne donc normalement mercure
l'analyse le raisonnement en capricorne
ce genre de titre qui parle peu mais qui
parle juste mars verso c'est simple tu
leur donnes un manuel
une technique un truc à faire ils feront
ils vont être chauds paix dont un stop
qui me jugent résultats oui ou non
oui
vous avez dû beaucoup rire quand il a
dit qu'il parlait peu mais encore une
fois c'est quelqu'un que nous on connaît
publiquement et qui parle beaucoup
publiquement on connaît pas dans la
vraie vie
par contre c'était assez bluffant il
s'agit de squeeze alors toi tu le
connais peut-être pas du coup il est
très créatif
je trouve ça collait vraiment avec la
partialité compressant nous de squeeze
parce qu'on peut pas se targuer de le
connaître vraiment tu vois mais ça colle
est ce qu'on imagine de lui et en tout
cas des qualités que time is il faut les
avoir pour être à sa place aujourd'hui
donc ça fonctionne très bien nous sommes
le 31 juillet 1914 il est une heure du
matin un homme les uns est clairement
rien donc 31 juillet 14
ok ok bon caractère dominant dominant
dominant ges les lyons et je suis le roi
le centre le chef etc
le lion considère qu' des centres du
monde là où l'adulte après conscience
qu'il n'est qu'un grain de sable dans le
désert
et c'est d'autant plus un vrai dominant
le second rôle le profond la lune
elle était en scorpion aucun signe de
combat donc c'est un type qui est
branché combat en permanence il est dans
les rapports de force en permanence
je suis sans arrêt dans une sorte de
mécanisme de rapport de force de
d'intuition un peu parano serait trop
fort mais d'intuition un peu anxiogène
de qui va me bouffe et de l'espace qui
va être
manipulés qui lui aussi l'amérique le
cancer comme proussy souvient mémoire
d'éléphant et sert à bélus en vierge
mais aussi venus l'amour en vierge très
très chaud et très réservé sur les
sentiments qui donc tout le temps dit
certainement qu'on lui porte
les marsan vierge encore un pin ailleurs
en fait quelqu'un car encore dans le
détail je peux dire tout de suite qui
sait quand je vais vous dire qu'ici ça
va sur vous surprendre cette lecture
mais si vous prenez le temps de
découvrir sa vie des reportages cette
personne vous allez voir à quel point on
s'approche de cette lecture là c'est
louis de funès un génie comique est un
tyran avéré domestiques et
professionnels
sauf que ça marche très très bien pas la
tâche possible parce que personne au
dessus de moi etc
il a une interview d'ailleurs été très
inspirante sur le fait d'avoir un
metteur en scène ou pas de se faire déjà
digéré j'ai dirigé le camp se manger de
se faire diriger par quelqu'un est tout
sommes sur un homme né le 15 juin 1943 à
13h peut changer cette géniale idée
c'est pas faux c'est pas faux c'est pas
faux bond ça montre le net et notre ami
j'arrive
bon bah oui c'est johnny et en place
soit nicole la préparer c'est moi qui
avais dit fait devenu si vous l'avez
changer contre jan hommen eddy mitchell
cheveux maintenant c'est bon on fait
johnny k eh bien eh ben non bah écoute
on va s'arrêter là tu sais quoi parce
que le dernier c'était moi et je me dis
que plutôt que de le faire en enveloppes
ce sera un très bon sujet pour une
nouvelle vidéo ensemble où tu m'as
prendre un même peut-être à la gym et d
ali remontée absolument hockey de mon
cas c'était une vidéo passionnant merci
beaucoup
j'espère que vous avez apprécié ça en
regardant avec un certain lâcher prise
un quelque chose à l'aveuglé ce que ça
donne et à quel point ça peut marcher il
y aurait énormément de choses à dire
dessus le plus simple en fait c'est
d'aller voir directement sur la chaîne
de gens il je vous la met dans la
description à l'appareil juste là au
dessus de moi et il y aura un petit
cercle et à la fin c'est assez marrant
pour moi d'avoir vécu ça parce qu'en
fait c'est ce que je sois encore redding
et lui le fait avec ces outils là alors
oui peut-être aussi qui qu'il analyse
consciemment ou inconsciemment mes
propres réactions puisque moi je savais
qu'ils étaient dans les enveloppes ça
aurait pu être aussi intéressant
d'essayer de faire ça en double aveugle
c'est à dire que même moi je ne sache
pas ce qu'il ya dans le bloc et
personnes dans la pièce ne sache on l'a
pas fait comme ça on l'a fait pour
découvrir son métier
c'est en tout cas ce que fait jean il
vous intéresse je vous recommande
vivement d'aller sur sa chaîne découvert
ça il fait des horoscopes il parle des
points positifs et négatifs de certains
signes il parle du futur de tels singh
explique aussi comment ça se passe son
métier voilà si vous êtes curieux comme
moi vous savez que moi par exemple j'ai
beaucoup lu sur la chiromancie la
lecture des lignes de la main ça pas
dire que je crois dans les lignes de la
main mais ça m'a pas empêché de
m'intéresser aux sujets et bien vous
pouvez aller sur la chaîne de jean yves
et moi je vous dis à très bientôt
la semaine prochaine 6h ciao